i have a question for you bernie because
uh you were the nypd commissioner
around 9 11 right during 9 11. so
taking it back to i'm i'm 40 past 42 41.
um i remember being this is 25 years ago
i remember being 15 years old
late 90s mid 90s and literally calling
up and asking one of my best friends who
was like a computer geek
hey jeremy what's the difference between
the internet and email
uh can you just break that down for me
buddy i literally had no idea
1996 right okay so five years later
we're dealing with 911. you brought up
96 i think i bought remember the
american express had a had a thing you
can buy
a a computer online and people were
buying computers and i was like
dude i don't know why would i ever need
a car why would i need a computer
you know aol account i'm going to get an
aol account right
who just sold who just uh they sold the
joint
exactly and they lost the exclamation
point so they're not excited about it
yahoo used to have the exclamation point
is not yahoo yes correct but it used to
be yahoo with an exclamation point they
took that away
meaning they're not too excited here's
my question for you so
we're going back 20 years or so what
were the major concerns back then
pre-9 11 and even post 9 11
versus what they are today we talked
about cyber and this malware and
taking down the grid but so bring us
back to what the world looked like 20
years ago when you were running the show
running the show versus what it looks
like today i think back then
um you know we weren't as concerned with
cyber as we are today not not even close
not even close
today is a it's a major could be
a major national security threat back
then
it was the criminal element in the nypd
we had a big intelligence component
we had been attacked prior
the radical muslim
you know groups we were familiar with
we were concerned with um and and
the organized crime change you know
years ago
up until uh i guess the 2000s
you know a lot of the organized crime
major organized crime in new york city
was
italian right the mafia
um you know today when the fbi says you
know they've
they've hit the mafia they've you know
they're taking out a
a substantial organized crime mafia
group
the guy's 90 years old he's coming out
of his [ __ ] house in a bathroom
like really dude you know you know what
i mean it's amazing
you know they get them out to the car
today it's the russians
today it's a chinese uh things like that
those organized crime groups are serious
concerns
um terrorism a serious concern in new
york city
only because we've been through it we
are i think new york city is still the
primary terrorist
target in the united states um
but cyber is one of the most uh most
important
pre-9 11 how big of a concern how high
of a red of alert
was a terrorist attack like the world
trade center was it
well it was still it was high and there
were things we were always concerned
with keep in mind
you know the mass transit system we have
you know five
million people that go through the mass
transit system on a daily basis in new
york city
you know you drop uh you know some
chemical agents in the subway system at
five o'clock
at grand central station you've got a
major
problem um so these are always these
were always
concerns of ours you know in the
aftermath of the attack on the morning
of september 11th
after the planes hit the buildings we
shut down
the mass transit system we evacuated the
other buildings in new york city
you know that had major height on them
uh worried about
incoming planes worried about you know
the third plane
fourth planes we didn't know how many
planes were out there but we also
shut down the mass transit system got
everybody out of the subway system
because i didn't know if there were more
attacks planned i didn't know if there
was something going to happen
on the ground you know a coordinated
attack like this you don't know
you don't know what they did you only
know what you're getting at the time
um what did they have planned did they
have coordinated attacks
planned on the ground you know um
shore up the synagogues shore up the
churches um the government buildings
uh the mass transit these are all things
that we had to worry about at the time
and and you were you were you were with
giuliani right you were escorting
giuliani around because there's a
what's the whole story with you and
mayor giuliani during uh 9 11.
well when when the first plane hit tower
one i was actually in my office
giuliani was uptown he was at a
breakfast and i was in my office and my
chief of staff and one of my security
guys came in banging on the door that
a plane had just hit tower one
and i thought they were a little overly
excited because i
thought that that plane would be a small
cessna or one of these small areas you
did not think it was a terrorist attack
no the morning no i thought you know
what i thought it was i thought it was
one of these small planes that could fly
up and down the hudson river
the helicopter is a small aircraft you
know taking people in and out of lower
manhattan
and uh then all of a sudden i looked up
at
i had a tv in my office above a
treadmill in the back of my office
and i could see the damage to the
building and i
walked out to my phone at my desk i
called the mayor
and he said i'm on the way downtown i'll
meet you at seven world trade that was
where the emergency command center was
for the city
so uh i got dressed because i was
standing there taking a shave when this
happened
i got dressed uh and i was down
to the entrance of vesey street probably
within seven or eight minutes
um got down to the corner uh came down
west broadway went to turn on the vessey
and there were cops there
and a sergeant came up to my vehicle saw
me in the backseat i had my window down
saluted me and said boss you can't get
onto the block they're jumping
and i didn't i didn't know what he was
from the building yeah
i got out of the vehicle walked to the
corner of vessey
and i could see this debris coming off
the building um and then it's
you know within seconds i realized that
the debris that i saw coming
off the building wasn't really debris it
was people and they were coming down two
or three at a time
so we backed the vehicles up west
broadway to barclay
waiting for the mayor in about three
minutes before he arrived
the second plane blew through the north
side of the tower so when you
when you see that big orange fireball
blow blow out the north side of
trade center two i was standing under
that
fireball and we were looking up and i
didn't know
i didn't know at the time what that was
because i didn't see that plane that
plane came in from the southern end of
manhattan
and then i could hear the aviation
pilots uh our pilots the helicopter
pilots
in the nypd yelling that a second
aircraft had just hit tower two
so it was at that it was at that moment
that i realized that we were under
attack
we didn't know anything about dc didn't
know anything about the pentagon hadn't
happened yet
pennsylvania nothing nothing none of
that stuff that was
another half hour behind us the mayor
got there in about three minutes
we looked at the front of the building
the mayor wanted to go down to west
street we walked
literally walked to west street over by
the financial
center looked at the damage to tower one
and two from that side of the street
and then i brought him back to exactly
where we picked him up at barclay and
west broadway
so he could call the white house he
wanted to call the white house who
wanted to call president bush and ask
for air support
and we were in that
we were in that office with the mayor
and my executive staff some of the
deputy mayors
when tower two imploded and it was it
was only about
a hundred yards from us there so
basically it imploded on top of us
pretty pretty i mean everybody remembers
where they were at with 9 11. so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye